thank you chair um so yeah as as stated
I'll be given a brief overview of four
particular areas of enforcement carried
out by the public health and Community
safety service so it should be seen in
the context that the service
itself um encompasses regulation under
around 50 pieces of legislation and
Associated regulation and orders so um
this is um a significant but small area
of the um work of the service so I'll be
focusing on four sorry just gone that
too far ahead already um four areas
namely statutory nuisance antisocial
Behavior private sector housing and
empty homes now these are all quite
meaty and big areas in their own right
so this will necessarily be a brief
overview um and obviously if you have
any question questions that's where
you'll probably get a lot of value out
of it okay so moving on to statutory
nuisance so I think it's helpful to
outline what is statut nuisance um at
first so statut nuisance is actually
laid down in legislation so it's in the
Environmental Protection act it's laid
down it includes things such as smoke
smell
accumulations animals kept in certain
States insects light and noise so there
are others there's there's tents Vans
sheds ponds pools ditches there's all
sorts but anyway um those are the most
common ones I suppose and noise is our
our sort of biggest complaint if you
like so we receive 200 to 250 complaints
a year about
noise um be that commercial noise that's
a potential nuisance or neighbor noise
that's a potential nuisance and some of
those will go on to turn into um
antisocial Behavior cases which we'll
come on to um other potential Nu is
between 50 and 75 a year so this is your
bonfires things like that quite common
light is growing I suppose um so it's
important to point out statute nuisance
is a statutory duty if we receive a
complaint about a potential statutary
nuisance then we have a duty to
investigate that complaint now that
investigation can take all sorts of um
um it can take all sorts of different
looks so for example for noise we might
ask for diary sheets someone to complete
diary sheets very important first step
in our investigation um and that could
constitute the investigation and we
might close it once we receive those if
there's not enough on them to Warrant us
us moving further so we have a duty to
investigate if we've determin a staty
nuisance which is a determination made
by our officers who are trained um to
determine such matters um then we have a
duty to serve a notice so we have a duty
to to serve an abatement notice under
the ACT um we don't serve a huge number
of mment notices we serve two or three a
year
um it's safe to say that in the majority
of complaints we receive it does not
amount to a statutary nuisance in the
majority of complaints we receive or
it's dealt with by another um method so
as I said with noise sometimes that goes
down the ASB route because it doesn't
meet the thresholds for stategy
nuisance um just worth saying with noise
we don't have to um serve the notice
straightway it's the only one we have
seven days in which we can pursue
alternate um alternate um
arrangements to Abate the
nuisance um as I said we currently have
three outstanding abatement notices two
of which are under appeal and all of
that is quite time consuming so with all
enforcement and this this goes to
everything I say today with all
enforcement we work in line with the
enforcement policy
of the council which is to negotiate
first negotiate educate so we would
always approach someone you know now
obviously there are degrees and that
depends if you turn up and something is
for want of a better explanation a death
trap is imminent risk to somebody then
we're going to want to take action
straight away but generally speaking
unless that is the case we will try and
work with people to change behavior and
bring about the change that we
want um so there's no particular
threshold for statute Nuance it's down
to the Judgment of the investigating
officer and as I said earlier officers
have been trained we've even been on
training courses to calibrate our sense
of smell um I haven't done that one but
our officers
have um I do what i' to be interested to
do that one because I don't think mine's
brilliant but there we go luckily I
don't have to go out and um smell things
um
[Music]
so it's worth reiterating here so
majority of cases there is no statut
nuisance established that can be for a
number of
reasons but it might still be an
annoyance so things can be annoying but
they don't necessarily meet the
threshold of Statute nuisance okay so if
it doesn't it can sometimes go down the
ASB route which is
um which we'll come on to
um the remain blah blah blah ignore that
sorry I'm just looking at this I've said
most of this already so I shall move on
um I was going to do questions at the
end if that's okay chair yeah yeah okay
so antisocial Behavior so similar so
antisocial Behavior among other
things the antisocial Behavior crime and
policing act 2014 gave us a number of
powers um you'll be aware of the public
spaces protection orders for example um
for the drinking and antisocial behavior
in the center and um dogs and
fowling um so these are to address
Behavior AV that have a detrimental
impact on the quality of life of those
in the locality is of a persistent and
continuing nature and is
unreasonable so this is a power not a
duty so this is where this differs from
the statutary nuisance so we don't have
to do this um this is something that we
we have a power to do um obviously it's
something that we we want to do it's
desirable for us to do in certain
circumstances it's just worth mentioning
the difference between the power and the
duty because when it comes
to um if we have tight resource for any
reason at any particular time then
obviously those Duties are going to take
precedence over the powers that we have
those are the things that we can whereas
if we ignore a duty then we can be held
up um as a council for uh not um
undertaking
those so we currently serve um receive
around 50 complaints of antisocial
Behavior a year in the service
um which is not a huge number but as I
say those some of those nuisance
complaints are antio Behavior complaints
and they do transfer over to that to
that route um for for noise for
example
um sorry I'm just I was just sett all
that so the ACT requires us to issue a
warning letter that's actually important
so we we can skip it so when we when we
receive a complaint of antisocial
behavior from a
resident what we do is investigate in
the first instance and establish whether
we feel it is that behavior of a
persistent continuing nature that's
going to cause a detriment to the
community and is unreasonable if we
determine that that is the case um we
will then usually go down a series of
warning letters so we don't go straight
to notice now the the legislation
requires us to serve a warning notice
before a warning letter should I say
it's not a notice before going to notice
there are circumstances which we can
skip straight straight to the end but
generally speaking we wouldn't cuz we'd
be open to challenging call so we go
down a a route of of of
warning um as I say we receive around 50
complaints a year of these we issue
around 10 between 10 and 20 warnings a
year and usually one to two notices
following those warnings so it it you
know goes down as we as we go along
along um we have the pspos which I've
already mentioned um so there have been
24 dispersal orders issued for the um
Town Center pspo um since its Inception
that's due for renewal in April next
year I
believe and it's worth saying here as
well we're active members of the
community safety partnership um which
also comes under the antisocial Behavior
although it deals it has a much wider
remit the community safety partnership
the community safety partnership is not
the antisocial Behavior partnership that
is a again a small part of its work so
it has four priorities about protecting
the vulnerable domestic abuse and sexual
violence substance misuse and emerging
threats so that is like a wide quite a
wide remit um we are going to along with
um North Devon start chairing the
community safety partnership soon we're
in transition now from from Toby Davis's
superintended
um
oh just worth mentioning actually I've
just got written here the community
trigger so the community safety
partnership has duties around the
community trigger so if someone feels
that their complaint is not being
investigated or has not been dealt with
appropriately they can issue a community
trigger which I believe now is called an
antisocial Behavior
review um and that's something for the
Community Partnership to consider so um
we've had three Community safety uh or
antisocial Behavior reviews or Community
triggers um this year none of which have
met the thresholds so we we haven't um
actually formally investigated any of
those we've looked into them they
haven't met the
thresholds uh so private sector
housing uh another big area of work uh
very wide ranging so essentially
involves the Housing Act 2004
and and Associated regulations I suppose
to do with the private rented sector but
again we have duties so the Housing Act
04 requires us to investigate any
complaints made about um standards in
private rented accommodation or in
private accommodation it's 10 year blind
so we can potentially take action
against owner occupiers with this
legislation um it wouldn't normally
happen to be fair but we can potentially
do
it so we also have duties to assess the
quality of the stock in our area um
which we have done in the past and we
have some of those surveys um we're
going to be updating those in the coming
um years next couple of years we're
going to be updating um that information
and that allows us to perhaps Target our
uh resources um in a more effective way
so when we assess a dwelling if we find
a category one Hazard which is just a
serious Hazard to the health and safety
of um individuals that reside there or
visit um then we have a duty to take
action so there's another Duty there we
have duty to serve serve notice
essentially under the ACT um to resolve
that issue in the best ways we see fit
so we receive around 50 complaints a
year about private housing conditions um
we currently have about 10 outstanding
notices some of which are prohibition
orders which prohibit either part or all
of a dwelling for certain uses or for
entry for
example so we're planning to undertake
some stock modeling as I've said which
will give us a clearer picture of where
we might need to Target resources in the
future um so this will provide us about
predictions of Hazards in properties it
will provide us about the status of
properties such as whether they're
houses in multiple occupation which are
slightly higher risk Properties or not
um once we have this we'll start a
gradual proactive program um to look out
to those um reaching out to households
and potentially areas
that may have issues and we can offer
help with the financial assistance
policy but also um we can then start to
look at engaging with those landlords to
improve conditions if they're private
rented um and last but by no means least
empty properties which is um an issue
that all of you will be aware
of so the first question we need to ask
ourselves when we receive a complaint
about an empty property is how long has
it been empty
if it's been empty for less than 2 years
then we don't class it as long-term
empty things can be empty for our 2
years sounds like a long time but
probate for example there's all sorts of
reasons why properties can be empty for
a certain amount of time once it gets
over the 2E then that's that's a
long-term empty property so we currently
have 76 properties classed as empty for
more than two years um in torage now
empties provide us with a particular
challenge
because on the face of it and we'll come
to it in a second there is a piece of
legislation that allows us to take over
management of the property and bring it
back into use which sounds like a silver
bullet um that's called The Empty
dwelling management order on an edmo
might hear people talking about um it
isn't actually that much of a silver
bullet it's incredibly administratively
burdensome for the authority um and
costly so we would have to pay to bring
that that property up to a lettable
standard which in a lot of cases most
cases for empty properties would be a
substantial amount of money now we can
claim that back with the duration of our
management which is up to 7
years but it doesn't take a lot for that
to become untenable financially because
we also have to claim back any
management costs Etc
so unless it was like a new build
property and in in a very good state of
repair it would be probably not suitable
for for an
edmo um so the only other two things we
have with regards to Bringing empty
properties back into use um as a kind of
nuclear option if you like is the Ed
mode the compulsory purchase of the
property so we we purchase it and bring
it back into use similar problems we
don't have the finance to purchase
properties um and even if we did then
we've got to have the finance to bring
them up to a elble standard Etc so the
same problem resides um the most likely
one I suppose is enforced
sale um where we get charges on the
property we get a substantial charge on
the property for doing other works and
then we can enforce the sale of that
property to get our money back
essentially um and that forces a change
of hands um but again that is
problematic um for reasons I'll come on
to so because those are the sort of
nuclear options the only other options
we have is a kind of campaign I suppose
of
um of enforcement action of smaller
enforcement action against the property
so if the guttering is faulty for
example it's causing damp to a neighbor
that could be a potential strategy
nuisance um it's overgrown and there's
harborage for pests uh it's open to
access and vandalism so we can take
action against the owner for a myriad of
things and then we can do default Works
which because a cost for the authority
but then we can charge that put that as
a charge on the property um the issue
there is in most cases people will pay
it so we don't get the charge so we
can't then go on to enforce sale even if
the charge was high enough um but we can
we can do that so that's essentially our
approach to empty properties is to try
and bring about Behavior change by just
keeping on addressing issues with the
property with the owner um to try and
force a behavior change or that they
have eventually get fed up and either
bring it back into use or or sell the
property um
themselves uh
so I don't think I want to go
into any more details about that or it
it should be noted actually that you can
use um the ASB legislation for empty
properties in a similar way so it's not
a silver buet it's in the same way as
the other legislation so you can um
require if it's having a detrimental
impact to the community of a persistent
nature and is unreasonable you can
potentially use the ASB legislation and
go down the community protection notice
um route um with similar outcomes so
that you get potentially a charge on the
property or bring about the behavior
change um I think that's all I wanted to
say as I say it's been necessarily brief
hopefully it's not been
too
anyway there you go if you've got any
questions which I'm sure you
have uh Phil thank you very much um open
to the floor questions for Phil on
that councelor Cod Lankin um I was just
wondering about the numbers of empty
properties in previous years have they
gone down because of the action that's
been
taken um so we bring back into use um
three or four empty properties a year
now I'd like to take credit for all of
that but sometimes it's just happen
stance that we're involved with a
property and something happens for
example somebody might die or something
and the property changes hands and it
gets brought back into use so sometimes
it's
not solely because of what we're doing
but properties we're involved with about
three or four a year so it's not huge
numbers but yes we we are involved with
them um we tend to get involved when
there are complaints made about the
properties
um it's something that we need to look
at going forward with that proactive
work I was talking about but again it
will never be um it will never be these
huge numbers I don't think and with 76
although that is a substantial number
it's not it's not uh um you know it's
not something that we should be overly
concerned about I don't think we just
need to keep plugging away at it but
yeah three or four and how does it
compare with neighboring councils um
like neighboring districts how many
empty properties have they got for
example in North D right I don't have
those figures with me but I do believe
it favors fairly um or sorry we're it
looks okay with regards to other
districts only because of the recent
there was an article recently which
published all the figures for the
empties I think it actually got our
wrong um in the first instance and was
corrected but anyway um so I think we we
weren't near the top in Devon by any
means we were in the bottom half um in
Devon I can provide you with examp
figures um if You' like outside the
meeting
yeah Phil just following on on Council
cot Lin's question there
76 long-term empty properties in the
district greater than two years is that
figure going up or down I don't I think
that was where your question was in part
I don't think we quite answer that is it
is the situation getting worse or is it
improving um the situation is is not
getting worse as as far as I'm aware so
as I say I can provide you with some
statistics outside of the meeting but it
no I don't I don't think from my
experience it's getting worse um
certainly that that's not a number
that's gone up from previous years and
in fact I think that's where the
erroneous figure which was higher than
that came from um in the recent report I
forget where it was in like a Devon live
or something um but I think that's where
that figure came from was previous years
so I think it's going down but I can
provide you with the figures do you have
a feel for the split or division of
empty properties in the urban versus
rural areas I'm looking more at at
longer term utility um I'm aware of of
um empty properties in in in my patch in
in very rural winkly area which are so
isolated that actually if they were
brought back into use they wouldn't be
they wouldn't be of any you couldn't
nobody' want to rent them who who was
who are in the category that we are
worried about because they are
completely unserviced you if you haven't
got a car etc etc there' be no good do
we have any do we have an idea as to
what proportion of these properties are
largely in the in the towns um rather
than actually out in the in the in the
urban State I don't I'm right that's
just quite interesting because in terms
of where the priority might be on on
focusing work or or attention what I
would say on that is we are um currently
engaging with um John seam um Amy the
gis officer um about getting mapping
done and we've started that process so
we're mapping a lot of our um what's the
word Services now for one of the better
word so we're mapping out private Water
Supplies we can see where they are in
relation to if we get any pollution
incidents or what have you um and that
will be something that will go on there
cuz you're right if it's something in
the center of bford for example that's
something that's of interest to us in a
different way to Something in the middle
of no nowhere for you know a better disc
it might be a useful exercise to ask
counselors to um to let you know the
empty properties in their Wards you're
you might get a bit of a surprise your
numbers will go up
um Council C hin again as a Committee
Member I'm coming to you counc hes but I
was just wondering um if they're empty
for a really long period of time do they
then become derel is that is that
different from being empty if they've
got into such a bad State well there's a
few near me and it's like it would take
a lot to bring them back now yeah not
not from so it doesn't alter the um kind
of
legal perspective from our point of view
it doesn't alter that so that it would
still be the same Powers open to us so
it doesn't change um or suddenly give us
some additional Powers if if they're in
a certain State I suppose what it does
do is it means we've got more that we
could
potentially um more action that we could
potentially take against that owner if
it's in that kind of state um but then
again if it's a property that's sat in
the middle of a field for example as you
say and a property that's in a Terrace
that's going to have different impacts
on the neighbors and the
community so the priority would be for
us to take action in those cases if they
were in the same state in the Terrace
and the one in the field which isn't
arguably bothering anyone we probably
wouldn't look at that as a priority that
isn't so always remain as an empty
property even if it's like sort of lost
the roof and that or is that well no
actually sorry you're right so when it
comes to the point of that it's it's not
yeah it's not a property anymore I.E
it's it's lost all utility then yeah we
we wouldn't class that as um and in fact
I don't know whether Council class those
differently I think they do is there any
Duty then or is that not for us no okay
no not for
us Council hes you had a question
than
y thinking that yard big yeah that be
Beyond
it um yeah so I think you me mentioned
animals and the way they're kept um so
can you just clarify that um in terms of
what sort of powers you have um when
would when would that actually come in
when you would have to take action
that's one question another one
um as you know there's the property in
between noram and alador which is the
subject of um constant damage and uh
criminal Behavior which you're
investigating if you can sort of just
remind me or perhaps outside this
meeting perhaps of what sort of further
action you're taking as it's an empty
property um public spaces can you
confirm the public spaces on the Burrows
and uh Northern Burrows and in which
case are are there powers to control the
way people have um control their dogs in
terms of their impact on wildlife and
the other question is empty property uh
sorry properties which are in a poor
condition with mold I have a case in
appledore which is being pursued by an
officer uh about the problem is that the
landlord can't be um contacted or won't
respond so what do you do in that
situation that's thank you just to cut
in I I sorry I should have said at the
beginning that I agreed with officers um
that for all of these presentations this
morning it wouldn't be appropriate to
discuss individual cases please in
public um but the principal that's fine
um but but uh officers won't be
referring to individual cases can't be
answer that's yeah thank you thank you
no problem so um with regards the
animals and statut nuisance um the
nuisance around animals is animals kept
in such a manner as to be pred
prejudicial to health or a nuisance I
think I'm going to be quoted on that now
but anyway um so a such a state or
condition anyway um so it's about how
you're keeping animals so for example
and this is probably not what you're
referring to but it's important
distinction so one of the things we've
received complaints about a lot is is uh
people feeding pigeons for example
feeding pigeons seagulls what have you
um that wouldn't come under the animals
CU they're not keeping them they're just
feeding them so that's one distinction
um with the animals one one of the
things you can do for example if
someone's got dogs they're keeping in a
a yard or um out building
and by virtue of
that the dog excrement for example is
causing a problem or something then that
might be that they're keeping the animal
in such a way as to cause or as to be
prejudicial to health or nuisance
although under that we might do it under
accumulations it's something along those
lines so there are things we can do it's
about using the most appropriate power
so for example if it's animals it might
come under licensing and it might be
more appropriate to use it under
licensing if it's like a canal or
something along those lines or a breeder
um it it really does depend what it is
um that we're talking about but
certainly as I say we have a duty to
investigate those if you feel there's a
an issue
um I know we've had a number of
communications and I won't go into
specifics um about um that case I know
we've had a number of communications
about the specific case
um as I say and and we have gone back
and forward on on complainant it's
important for us to to deal with
complainants now while we will
investigate statutory nuisances
potential statutory nuisances or other
problems um that we're made aware of um
it's important for us to have
complainants for those and and the
reason for that is we need we need a
receptor we need to establish a receptor
for that nuisance so I.E if there's
noise it's like a tree falling in the
forest if there's noise being made but
no one's hearing it then that's can't be
a nuisance because it's not a nuisance
to anyone so it needs to be a nuisance
to someone so we can say well that's
potentially a nuisance there but is it
unless someone is being bothered by it
so unless we've received the complaint
we can't really establish uh the
nuisance that easily
um so it's it's worth saying worth
saying that with regards to um things
being open to access again we will go
out we will have a look at those um if
we feel it's open to access and it fits
within the legislation um we will seek
to close those properties to access
access um if we feel that's the most
appropriate course of action um I can
certainly pick up with you outside about
particular property you're talking about
it's not a problem at all um with
regards to the pspo yes we do have um
powers to uh in the pspo around dogs on
on leads uh dog fowling for example um
so again if you're experiencing
particular problems with that then
that's something um that you should get
in touch with with us about what I would
say on
that is enforcement of that is is tricky
over large areas so if we have three
officers for example we've got three
neighborhood officers they can't
possibly be covering the entirety of
that pspo so that we need to gather the
evidence before we can take action
against somebody so ideally we need to
see that or witness it firsthand um and
with three officers we're we're we're
not necessarily doing that um we do get
out we do have patrols um so we do get
out and about a couple of times a month
in different places in the summer we up
those to three or four times a week um
but again it's about resource of of you
know applying the resources
appropriately as
possible um and with mold sorry is this
mold are we talking about mold in a
privately rented property or right in a
privately rented property that's
something that the tenants so tenants I
presume have complained to us already
without going into specifics yes it's
empty now but you can't locate the land
so what you do now so if it was if it
was that bad in a theoretical exercise
if it was that bad and we were aware of
a property that had hazards significant
hazards we could potentially prohibit
use of that property um potentially if
the hazards were significant enough um
so we can take enforcement action if if
we can't um establish who the owner or
establish contact with the owner we can
still take enforcement action against
that if if we deem it to be the most
reasonable course of action So yeah
thank very
much so thank you I uh Mr
har just one question how do you deal
with frivolous
complaints
um it's an interesting point actually I
don't think we get that many what I
would say frivolous complaint so I
suppose we we do get a number of
complaint there's always a reason I
think um why people are complaining we
can always see that reason now whether
there's anything we can do about that is
is that gray area um is probably what
you're you're talking about I think um
and yet it's just about being clear in
in our Communications with those people
that this is not something that we can
deal with we can see why you've
complained about this this is an
annoyance or what whatever it might be
but we can't we can't do anything about
it we don't have powers so we don't get
any
frivolous um in
the iose yeah it's the use of the word I
suppose we get complaints that we can't
deal with but I don't think we get
complaints for the sake of it if you
like one last
question where would you like to do more
that you can't at the
moment um so I
think well that's that's a Hostage to
fortune that is because I would be want
to say well everywhere of course you
know it would be nice but but no I mean
I think we're we're doing and what I
would say I've not been at torage long
and I would like to say that the service
that I have come into is is a is a high
performing service so in my experience
of working local government we take a
lot of enforcement action we don't shy
away from enforcement action there are a
number of prosecutions that have
happened in recent years there's ongoing
work um in that area now there's notices
out there's appeals there's all sorts so
they are doing the work and it's really
great to see um for my part and again
just down to my experience I would say
that private sector housing is something
where and I've said in in here that you
know we will have all seen the news
stories recently and private sector
housing I say recently it's not that
recent anymore but in the last couple of
years about private sector housing about
damper mold um um and the prominence of
private sector housing is is Raising um
so what you would hope to see is
complaints also going up as well and and
we don't see that so there's something
there and I think that's worthy of
Investigation but I think that's that's
yeah that's the only area that I see
that sort of says to me right we need to
we need to look into that over the next
couple of years and that's where these
surveys they're not surveys as such it's
stock modeling that we'll do um will
help us to try and pinpoint if there are
um areas hotpots where we should be
putting a bit more
resourcing um last one councilor Craig
yeah just sort of picking picking up
that point um because I've often found
when that there have been sort of like
noise complaints or things like that
even smells of illegal substances uh
people are often reluctant about uh
reporting them do you think that that's
uh something that the council can do to
to support people and make them uh have
more faith in the that there will be a
response yeah well they can certainly
have faith that there will be a response
um I I I agree with you on um we do need
to look at confidence for for example
tenants it's not just tenants but
tenants who worry about the security of
their um tency for example now we do
have the retaliatory eviction powers
that came in so if we serve a notice
they the landord can't serve section 21
for
example um in certain circumstances it's
not as straightforward as it should have
been I don't think the government are
obviously looking to remove section 21
altogether I don't know whether that's
going
to be the Panacea that they're making
out we'll see um how that pans out but
yes I I think it's difficult isn't it if
you're a tenant and you're
feeling uh vulnerable
um and you know the scarcity of private
rented accommodation that you can afford
etc etc then you are going to think
twice before putting in a complaint
about that that might mean your landlord
says right out you go and even if then
someone says all right that's illegal
eviction and takes that landlord to
court that doesn't necessarily solve
your problem so I think you can there's
an understandable reluctance in some
cases but I think we do need to reach
out more and we do need to try and lay
some of those spes and hopefully the
changes with the section 21 will make a
difference in that area as
well so thank you very much indeed for
the comprehensive report there and uh we
are conscious that whilst you're sat
here talking to us you can't be out
there doing your job um and therefore it
is always a balance um between taking up
offs of time uh and actually um hearing
directly from the horse's mouth so thank
you very much indeed no problem thank
you
moving um straight on to
um um item nine um moving into the
planning Arena now
um and we have our planning manager
Helen Smith who is going to um give two
reports to us one on planning
enforcement and how they manage that
and then um secondly on the delivery of
affordable housing uh both key
areas H over to you thank you chair and
good good morning all um I have prepared
written reports on this but there aren't
any slides for me to run through um the
enfor planning enforcement service
report begins on page eight of your
agenda um what I will do if it's okay
with you chair is just just talk through
some of the key elements of my report
and then I'm very happy to take any
questions or or clarify any points um so
so as as set out on on page eight of of
your agenda um the purpose of this
report and me being here today is to
give you an update on the council's
planning enforcement service um and
specifically just to highlight the
context within which we operate as a
service and also to highlight some
emerging changes in terms of that legis
legislation that we we work within um
but also to highlight current case loads
our current resourcing that we have in
place um how we Benchmark against other
councils within the Southwest in terms
of our enforcement service and then the
last section is sort of just to to
highlight with you all um some
improvements we're looking to make and
work we're doing in that regard so in in
terms of policy and legislative context
um section 171a of the Town and Country
planning Act of 1990 sets out what a
breach of planning is um linked with
this the the general permitted
development order um as amended um sets
out certain operations that don't need
planning but also there is a there is a
remit within that that if things don't
fall within the provisions of permitted
development then again it is a breach of
planning in terms of policy the national
planning policy framework does provide
guidance and our adopted local plan has
a specific policy around planning
enforcement so that's policy
dm1 I think what's really important to
highlight sort of at the start is that
um there isn't a statutory Duty upon us
as a planning service to take
enforcement action we have powers to
take enforcement action but it is a
discretionary service so we we we don't
have have to have Enforcement Officers
we don't we don't have to take
enforcement action we choose to do that
under the powers powers that we that we
have um just just moving on so on page
nine so this is section three I've just
included a table to show the pattern of
reported cases over over the last
thousand years and and you will see from
from the table at the top of the page
there there was a significant increase
in number of cases being reported in
2021 so that was sort of increase of
over 100 um cases which was was
significant and the resourcing for the
service hasn't hasn't changed to um you
know in light of that um and that's that
number throughout 2022 and certainly as
we approach the end of this year is now
consistently above 300 cases being
reported in terms of the resourcing of
the service we have two permanent
full-time enforcement officers and their
sole remit is planning
enforcement however as I will come on to
they do not work in isolation and are
are well supported by various members of
The Wider development management team
the conservation officer and building
Control Officers as necessary and they
do also work closely with with Phil
Phil's team the Environmental Protection
Team because often complaints that are
made to us um often raise issues with
Environmental Protection or suited
to we have an adop which
is group so high
PRI
we get but they are of significant
importance because of the other sort of
offenses that are associated with
unauthorized works in those cases and
then uh currently everything else is
afforded a medium
priority and on
page types
of breach that we to get some
comp are just
not
on
page I've set out the sort of
enforcement
procedure thought it would be
help
the
um letter um sent out to the
complainant our system
officers will do
ini
assessment
it of
case when they've pulled together their
their site visit notes and have
investigated matters such as planning
history um etc etc the there is then a
need to establish whether there has been
a breach of planning control and to
support the two Enforcement Officers at
that stage they have a regular weekly
meeting with the two development
management team leaders who are
qualified um town planning officers and
they will go through the cases on a
weekly basis and to provide advice as to
whether um there is a planning or not um
if there isn't the case is closed and
the complainant is notified if there is
a breach of planning then we move on to
the next stage where it's necessary to
establish well how how much of an issue
is this breach of planning would
permission be granted um if permission
would be granted it's then to establish
whether a planning application is needed
we wouldn't always insist that a
planning application is submitted
however if it is a breach that would in
principle be acceptable but would Ben
conditions for example to control
whatever that unauthorized development
is we would we would encourage and
invite a a planning application and
there is remit under the planning laws
to submit applications retrospectively
for works that have already happened um
if it's something that is unacceptable
we then move to a further test of
whether it is expedient to take
enforcement action so this is how
planning enforcement differs in terms of
the principal tests that are applied
expediency looks at whether it's in the
public interest whether there is such a
level of harm that that action formal
proceedings is needed and at that point
the the the team's development manager
has a regular meeting with the
enforcement officers and also a month
importantly a monthly
meeting as
well Point um there are wider
considerations of pursuing legal action
and ultimately the deleg there isn't
delegated authority to us and that sits
with the head of legal and governance to
to confirm whether we can move forward
or should indeed move forward with legal
proceedings um and then there are a
range of
options us to take action
there is a right
for individuals to enforcement
notied
enforcement Enforcement Officers would
engage with the conservation officer for
example if the site is within a
conservation area or if there are sort
of listed buildings
involved so
it
REM the enforcement
plan
bottom
all
no later than two working days of
receipt of the
complaint vast majority of
CAS that the
officers within
4 and original
complaint their
complaint page 11 so I've listed there
at the bottom of section three just the
the range of options there are in terms
of pursuing enforcement action um the
they are summarized in more detail in
the enforcement plan um the vast
majority of action that we take would be
around the serving of an enforcement
notice and before any of these actions
are pursued the best PR to um issue
what's known as a planning cont
contention notice which is um
essentially a set of questions which
seek to establish fact to inform any
further enforcement proceedings so just
moving on to section four um which sort
of details performance and capacity um
so as I mentioned earlier we do have two
permanent full-time offices we do also
have a temporary six month um full-time
officer at the moment so that post runs
from October through to um March of next
year
and um if I just sort of follow on to
the table below you can see that there
are a number of outstanding cases at the
moment Now sort of referencing back to
the table that I ran through at the
beginning which showed a huge jump in
case numbers around
2021 for various reasons um that has
resulted in a backlog of cases so I
think the in the qbrs from earlier this
year we it was indicated there were
Circa 500 outstanding cases with the
additional temporary resource that we
have and a very focused effort to reduce
that backlog we're now down to around
380 so there has been significant
progress made and it's also important to
highlight that it's not the position
that these are cases that have never
been visited or considered they will
have had site visits they will have had
some initial desktop desktop assessment
it is more than the the admin and
ensuring there is that me support with
more senior officers to to get those
closed down the the temporary resource
we have is is an exper very experienced
enforcement officer who has worked at a
range of councils within the Southwest
so there's an added benefit there and
that that he is bringing some context
from other authorities and can inform us
of some best practice from elsewhere um
so I would say that that we would hope
to see the real
benefit
res
of performance and you will have you
will have seen the the qbr um sort of
Statistics um generally the
acknowledgements within three working
days um we we're exceeding the target
there that
that rates really well the
high again as I said
earlier and is it within
two that
does
2% there only three cases so immediately
your your percentage is somewhat skewed
there um
the on the whole
is days
is the
obvious are
strugg
set is around
complaints that we get in cover a very
large geographical area it is hard to
efficiently manage two officers going
out and visiting every complaint within
two weeks um and I think there is a
question around whether that is I mean
great if we had a huge number of
enforcement officers that is something
we could certainly do but given the the
time scales for immunity from
enforcement I'll come on to with the the
changing and the leveling up in
regeneration act all enforcement
breaches will now be subject to a
10-year immunity period there isn't
necessarily a sense of urgency to
getting out within 14 days to all cases
so we're looking at whether that Medium
priority Cate category could be broken
down to a medium and a low and just
looking at a more manageable way of
officers getting out on site that's more
efficient and a better use of time um
the the further table on page 12 um I
just thought it would be helpful and
this is to the year ending due3 and
covers a two-year
period so this sets out um sort of
enforcement action that's been taken by
councils Across the southwest and and
you'll see that torage is
in terms of
Act is relatively High
perform
UMES served
to2
against is taken in appro in appropriate
circumstances um I would also highlight
though just number of notices served is
not necessarily A measure of success um
the starting point is always around
negotiation and that's why the
Pres negotiate and get a positive
outcoming a breach
with
the
ised
moving on to the
last some primary legislation that will
um will make changes to the planning
enforcement regime and I've just in
bullet points sort of set out those the
key changes that are coming forward now
these will be subject to
further
guidance year time Li
operational 10
years is that were 10 years whereas now
any any breach of
planning that's that's operational
development so a building Etc building
works is now subject to a 10-year period
within which we can we can take action
um temporary stop notice duration is
being extended from 28 to 56 days there
is the introduction of a temporary stop
notice for listed buildings a new
enforcement warning notice which is to
highlight where um a local planning
Authority considers there is a breach
but whereby it's considered there's a
reasonable prospect that planning
permission would be granted and this
offers a period for a planning
application to be
submitted um there are there are going
to be new me me to restrict the
opportunity to appeal against
enforcement notices and manage undue
delays now we do see quite frequently
appeals against enforcement notices that
are served um and you know I think it's
important to not we we've got a very
good appeal record in terms of um
inspectors upholding our enforcement
notices however it can be a very long is
already a long process even longer so it
is welcomed that there there could be
restrictions on the ability to appeal
and enforcement notice and also an
increase to the scale of financial
penalties for non-compliance with breach
of conditions and
non-compliance notices so those
financial penalties I think are ,000 at
the moment which when it when you're
sort of trying to take action over a
breach of condition on a very large
Housing
Development the threat of a, fine it it
tends to not make that that course of
action terribly effective um so that's
sort of the legislative framewor that's
changing and what we're looking at as a
service and and we're very conscious
that our you know the six month
temporary resource we have which we're
incredibly grateful for we have got this
set time scale where we we have that
capacity to really look at not just
reducing the case load but also how we
can operate more efficiently and more
effectively so that once that resource
that that temporary period has ended
that actually we can move forward in a
more a more effective manner so what the
team are doing um they are creating
templates to um help with the front
loading of complaints so the planning
support team have been briefed on those
but also templates to um make replying
closing down cases more efficient um we
do now have a monthly meeting with the
council's legal team which is a really
good way to have that sort of formal
regular catch up with with the legal
team in terms of looking at those cases
which may need to be pursued further we
are updating the enforcement plan
with the Lura but
ALS look
at
expectation so to look at that time
period because at the
moment say it it's just not a
realistic for them
to
trying
St
can
be so in what form um many councils
don't don't even have one enforcement
officer so would say two full-time
officers is is a good level of resource
um but what we're looking at is around
are there certain elements of those
tasks such as the admin side of things
that could actually be picked up by a
wider admin function um
to
efficiency as
well
and continue to
Eng Parish councils um through briefings
we've got a presentation that we'd like
to sort of roll out again in the spring
to parish councils and to members just
to um I guess it's
to to highlight what happens that we
don't have a statutory function that it
is discretionary all of those things
that hopefully if everybody sort of
understands the process that we can all
kind of work moving forward better
together and you know the complaints
that come through via members via parish
councils and members of the public are
crucial because um we certainly don't
have the resource to proactively be
going out around the district and
looking for where there may or may not
be breaches of
planning um and that is it chair I think
just the the conclusion is is very much
around
you know this this increase in cases
does seem to be here to stay I think we
can assume we're looking at 300 plus
complaints a year um I think on the
whole the service is performing well but
we do recognize there are areas we could
improve and work more
effectively um and we're we're confident
that the temporary six-month full-time
post that we have will support the
clearance of that backlog of cases um
and give us time to review our
enforcement plan to move forward um um
and I have I have including the
recommendation that I you know I would
certainly be happy to report again to
this Committee in the spring just to
highlight the the impact of that
resource okay thank
you Helen thank you very
much before before I ask questions
members of the committee have we got
questions on that for the planning
manager stunned in society stunned in
societ
um I'll if that's the case I'll ask my
question first councelor hes I know
you'd like to ask a question I'll come
back to you in in in a minute
um the way in which
you can monitor
that
approved
either committee
in a
delegate
is is
thin you are
entire general
public
is actually the quality of the
reporting um and sometimes neighborhoods
are quick to want to comment on what
they think are planning
contentions
sometimes um especially in
the perhaps
actually either is determined or arrives
in front of the plans committee and then
knowing how much discussion often there
is at plans committee people and not
just developers but anybody individuals
wanting to
to uh
develop tend to push things to the to
the the boundaries to the limits they
always do so the discussion with
planning officers is one of negotiation
to get it to in any likewise in plans
committee one can sit often his um
concern that things have been pushed too
far thereafter the breaks are off
because there's no oversight on that um
uh um development really um and that's
an area that would concern would concern
me and I know it's not a statutory
requirement
but the increase in planning
applications that we've seen since
20221 which has from a qbr point of view
a
dramatic income of from revenues for
Planning and Building control
fees um it's surprising
that we have only reacted with a
temporary post to increase the capacity
of planning
enforcement has
incre way the
work
greater has taken and put elsewhere and
not not
using um can you just comment on pieces
to
actually
condition number of
planet
to be proactive in
terms benefits
com
our uniform on our it system now
monitoring of all conditions on all
planning permissions I mean that it's
just not something I think any Authority
would ever have the resource to do um
something that has come out of our
conservation audit recently was a
question around more proactive
monitoring of conditions and something
we are going to look at is is whether we
can just highlight absolutely Key
conditions that actually we should be
more proactive around monitoring so
involving listed buildings and materials
and and quality of build um another you
know we we have occupancy restrictions
for example so there might be certain
conditions or certain sort of typologies
that that that would be Merit in
proactively monitoring so that's
something we're looking at
um yes we do rely on on members on
Parish councils on on the general public
to make those complaints to us um
however officers do note things when
they're on site so a lot of the
complaints are actually not not the
majority but some complaints are then
set up by officers when they've been to
look at a particular planning
application on a site visit and have
noticed actually what's going on here so
it's not solely to the public but
absolutely counceling eting that that
there is a huge Reliance on that and I
think linked with that that's why it's
important that we are engaging with the
parishes and members and the public and
that our enforcement plan is up to date
because that sets out that commitment
for how we do things so um also on you
know on the developers land owners um
owners of of
dwellings it is in their interest to
comply with conditions certainly we get
a lot of requests at due diligence stage
if a purchase if a property is being
sold and through land searches um
wanting confirm written confirmation of
compliance with legal obligations and
conditions and you know on the whole
those have been complied with but it can
impact on property sales and and further
contracts so there is there is that
incentive as well um some things are are
you know you can you can sometimes it
doesn't happen very often but have say a
mobile home that's been specifically
contained and hidden within a shed you
know if if there's that um intentional
containment then that doesn't benefit so
there there's lots of Provisions within
there I think going back to Resource and
whether we have the right resource in
place I think what I'm I'm Keen to do as
service manager is look at our processes
as a starting
point improve
those expectations of our whole
Community around
enforcement where there is
significant harm and it's expedient to
take action we are pursuing those with
with the legal team and you know Success
Through whether it's an enforcement
appeal or actually a
successful a really strong me pursuing
the way
through active measure to
take revenue and in we have
seen fees
to
to that
budet it could be coming um that said as
of the 6th of December planning
application Fe fees have increased under
legislation so now major applications
have seen a 35% increase in fee and it's
25% across all
application application
fees you
know and the
cost the revenue
from
planning um the consultation on planning
application fees did did seek a view as
to whether retrospective applications
should be subject to a double fee which
we certainly felt would be sensible but
that hasn't been brought in because
again that in itself would be a further
discouragement so um but budgets are
tight it's not you know not unique to
torage and not unique to us as a service
and you know it's it's crucially
important that we're putting most of our
resource and we're performing well in
terms of our statutory duties so that's
determining applications preparing a
local plan and we are very busy with
both of those things but I think it's
getting that that perfect balance isn't
it of upholding all of the hard work
that we're doing in terms of development
management and and involving plans
Committee in that as
well plan because if you don't have that
complete sort of triangle with
enforcement being effective then it
discredits everything else we're doing
so we're very aware of that but I think
what I would I would welcome the
opportunity to do is just see where we
are in March April and and just really
look at that the processes that we're
looking to change um and just see if if
that still works as two enforcement
offices but with some wider
support I I think we would um looking to
counsel us on the committee we I think
we would welcome a update centering
Around Your Capacity uh and where you
are with your backlog or not
um in the spring that would be that
would be helpful I I I hold back on
suggesting a recommendation at this
stage that we should um um raise concern
ultimately with the chief executive that
we feel you might be under resourced in
a certain area we're not in a position
to say that yet but it would be
interesting to see how you're getting on
um in that sense and um you know that
that is as much as we could do in that
area but it's something that we wouldn't
shy back from if we felt that you were
you weren't ad adequately resourced
is the increase in the workload is is
statistically very evident there isn't
any doubt uh in that um councelor haes I
haven't
forgot
question wrapped
into reply just like to say I'm very
impressed with the enforc officer who
own temp contract is doing very well
than you excellent um any other
questions on planning enforcement
for councel cun yeah you just mentioned
very
briefly
retrospect is
that that
wasment
consultation
individual applications
for taken place um and fees are set
nationally and the fee for for those
applications has always been the the
equivalent of what it would have been
were they submitting an application in
the first place prior to carrying out
the works um the the question question
posed in the consultation was around um
and I think you know as a potential
deterrent to to unauthorized Works was
around should fees for retrospective
applications be double what what the
equivalent planning fee would be um and
that hasn't been carried forward so we
we can't set our own um fees um and and
the the new fees that came in in this on
the 6th of December didn't take that bit
on board so there's not we can't do that
as a council okay no because you'd think
that that would
bring if if that was put in place you'd
think that that might help with the
number of Enforcement cases people would
look to put in the planning applications
rather than doing it retrospec yeah yes
potentially um but yeah that hasn't
hasn't been brought in at this
stage Mr Harper you have a question not
a question the point actually that the
lead member actually suggested that this
report be circulated to all parish and
town councils I think that's an
excellent idea Communications
important I was indeed was going to say
myself that this report that you've
written for um this committee is is a
very useful brief and and um we will
certainly recommend that it is more
widely distributed because um as you
quite rightly say um if you actually
tell people and
they the questions Fall Away uh or the
doubt Etc
so can I just can I can I make a
suggestion when when
you update
reports able to make um it might also be
a good time to think about your
expectations on qbr um t
one around
respon it
do that brief together has been um
almost helpful on your side as well
perhaps um it certainly created a useful
reference document which can be
used second
break two enforcement issues have
passed which
already
um again supported by a very
comprehensive uh
brief um can members please make sure
that you have that brief open in front
of
you
Helen you
go okay so
um I I did discuss this with um the lead
member for housing and what what I've
sort of put before you today very much
look at affordable housing delivery so
the policy context and and and some data
essentially um I I believe there might
be interest in a further session for
this committee looking in more detail
around you know what is affordable
housing what are those different ten
years which I don't propose to go into
today but it's just to highlight I would
be happy if there is anything that you
don't feel you've got out of this that I
would always be happy to to follow it on
with something else so so this report um
which is at page 16 of your agenda it is
essentially looking at the achievability
of the affordable housing targets that
are set out within the adopted local
plan um it it also has provided some
context to why 30% is is the policy
Target within policy
st18 um and also advisor of sort of
current opportunities and initiatives
that that are being considered to
increase affordable housing across the
District um recognizing it is a a prim
are of concern um section two I've just
sort of set out the national policy
context along with the socioeconomic
context which you you'll all be aware of
aware of the housing crisis and the
pressures um on um the ability for for
people to an affordable house um not
necessarily just in the true affordable
sense but to be able to get on that that
housing ladder um and The Wider
socioeconomic well-being impacts of of
that um National planning policy
framework sort of just set out text for
affordable housing provision um and
there is a a definition Annex two of the
mppf and I've just sort of Simply copied
that across Pages 16 and 17 of your
report um and then moving on to section
three where I've set out the current
local plan policy position so the the
October
20 and it has
statut which
essenti to go
through
purposes grow and includes a requir over
and above the Baseline housing need
that
by plan process so the
actual
across whole of
Northern
over and
this who are involved at that plan
making
step the plan
seeks housing
and the plan also seeks to influence
Housing Development
sites of housing
side separately to
a um
to large four and four and five bed
houses coming forward for example um the
plan also has specific policies around
housing and rural areas so rural workers
dwellings but also a policy for
exception sites in sort of our Villages
and local centers um specifically on
affordable housing policy
st8 subsequently updated by NA national
policy changes essentially requires 30%
of affordable homes um of homes on sites
of 11 or more dwellings to be provided
as
affordable or or on sites of greater
than 0.5 hectares so you could have a
site that's over 0.5 hectares and maybe
has four very large dwellings that would
trigger a need for affordable housing um
the tenure mix that is our our policy
requirement is of that 30% that
75% of those so the vast majority of
those affordable homes should be a
social rent tenure 25% should be an
intermediate provision vision and
there's a range of of sort of tenures
That Could Fall within that intermediate
range um very relevant to affordable
housing levels is part five of policy
st8 which states that negotiations to
vary the scale and nature of affordable
housing provision along with the balance
of other infrastructure and planning
requirement will be considered on the
basis of a robust appraisal of
development viability so there is a
mechanism for developers to seek to
provide less than 30% however they can
only do that where they have
demonstrated through a robust appraisal
that it's not viable to provide that
amount and we as a planning Authority
Always appoint an external expert to
scrutinize viability information that's
submitted um there is a supplementary
planning document on affordable housing
um This was um approved by the joint
planning
policy Committee in July of last year
and and again this recognizes site
viability
constraints um and has
to
provides um
the
expl inspect
L with this the the
housing needs
assessment Quantum
of up a
tar had a perent
um recognized also that there will be
locations in which housing values are
lower or there might be significant
development costs in terms of
infrastructure or site remediation
whereby residential development would
not be viable with the provision of 30%
affordable housing um so so what the
inspector ultimately confirmed was that
30% is was an appropriate level
important to recognize that's as a
Target it was never intended or expected
that all housing developments would
provide 30% it's an it's an upper Target
recognizing that reasonably you could
expect certain WR sites to be able to
meet that but equally other sites would
not be able to meet that
um just moving on to section four where
I've just sort of set out a bit of
context in terms of affordable housing
levels secured on planning permissions
um across the district um I think it's
important to note the the context of um
the bcis or intender Price Index
increases
increase the period November 2018 to
August
4.1
plan
date a
sign has been a recent sort of slight
change to the housing market as well to
that economic context is Ever
Changing um I think it's important to
highlight that as a the local planning
Authority does seek to ensure policy
requirements to a maximum extent but
Al delivery on allocated
another there is that
policy consider less
than
um there
is
section
document an
ability
positions might change over that um so
we are now on
on more
able
onsite affordable housing but there can
be scoped to secure offsite
contributions or other obligations
depending on you know preferences of
Ward members so the graph at the bottom
of page
199 and this this
shows we we do have
a housing delivery
area this is
a brought up to the the current day but
this sort of covers covers a period I
think to 2021 summer of 2021 so it
showed that 58% of sites in torage
District that were eligible for
affordable housing secured policy
compliant levels and the average amount
secured across all house eligible
housing developments was 21% and that's
against the target of 30% and that the
graph below just sort of highlights that
and it's interesting to look and is in
in the blue it shows that sort of
difference between what what's been
achieved on allocated sites which is 9
19% against non-allocated qualifying
sites which is to almost policy
compliant levels I think an obvious one
obvious explanation for that is um due
to the council having a period of time
without a five-year housing land Supply
applications did come in speculatively
usually on Greenfield sites where
perhaps there wasn't that level of in
infrastructure required um or
contamination or remediation
requirements where there was greater
capacity to secure that that almost
policy amount um and then just moving on
to page 20 the the housing and economic
development needs assessment um that
informed the torage local plan as an
Evidence base that set out an estimated
annual level of a FW housing need of 345
dwellings perom now with with the supply
that was secured through the local plan
and setting the 30% Target which the
inspector
did for the
planning that was never going to be
possible to meet the identified need um
I have set out sort of further on page
20 just some examples of schemes which I
won't run through now but just showing
that that that variety of
level of policy compliance and that um
2021 some
large loated
s levels
of
most
albe it the delivery of those and the
phasing will be over a considerable
amount of time um in terms of other ways
of securing affordable housing we do
have an exception site policy which
looks at um affordable lead schemes
coming forward on the edges of local
centers Villages and Rural settlements
there has been very limited uptake of
this policy due to us not having a
fiveyear land Supply um land owners
perhaps have been sort of wanting to to
see to achieve open market levels which
is more possible during that time there
is also the AFF affordable home Grant
system that operates separately via
homes England funding as well um so
there are other other means so page 21
just sets out some
completion delivery rates for dwellings
and affordable units there for you um
and then moving on to sort of the the
last section which which just highlights
sort of opportunities for approaches
that could be taken moving forward so
both north Dev and torge councils have
now resolved to move forward with a new
local plan there will be a need to
update evidence bases for to inform
housing levels employment levels um
affordable housing need and also there
will be need to be a strategic viability
assessment so what I've set out here is
some work that was done to um
for the joint planning policy Committee
just to look at how we can um perhaps
more accurately identify sites for
development that have have the best
prospects of achieving the 30% but
recognizing that there will be certain
sites where there are just wider
benefits of them being brought forward
for development for example the great
torington creary site significant
viability issues but there are such
overwhelming benefits in Redevelopment
of that site that the lack of affordable
housing was was outweighed um and then
finally we we I've I've set out just how
we could maybe look at other ways to
facilitate H housing delivery and again
this is on page 22 so looking to sort of
diversify thatly supply chain what sort
of sites do we want
to
um self
and at greater
SC
restrict and this is more
around from what theyve done um and and
then finally page
22 there are
some we're undertaking as um
look
to to look their grant funding program
and how there may be scope for
intervention um wider
engagement
torage we're looking to
increase sharing
knowledge
ensuring liability testing is really
Rob and
Chen we
wide um approach to housing delivery so
um that's a really exciting prospect and
also our remit will feed into the the
housing strategy along with the other
housing teams across so there is lots
we're doing
um and I think that's it
chair Helen again thank you very much
for a a detailed brief and also a very
comprehensive written
brief
um questions ladies and
[Applause]
gentlemen stun silence
again um
yeah who's going first I allow
Peter come on in councelor who El you at
this stage whilst committee members just
uh Sor on the viability assessment you
talk about very early stages at
hat um what happens if it considered
that a particular
site would not produce viability that
would be struck off the list how
rigorous this process the Strate do you
mean in terms of the local plan councel
homes yeah so
Strate it's an
interesting in there planning practice
guidance around um the scope of
viability appraisal it's not it's not
visible or practical for every site
allocation to be subject to a detailed
site
appraisal
um
information where certain types
of together
did um
increase vision of
various
andc
done some of our bigger ations and
indeed are strategic
allocations to go
in
um but
buted
in prejudicial to a site coming forward
such as significant infrastructure costs
then that through the Healer
process yeah um through through the
Healer process would would have to be
considered and actually through the site
allocation process um it's a balance
isn't it because there could be certain
Brownfield sites where there's wider
benefits so they may not be viable for
affordable housing but there there's
benefits to them being redeveloped so
that's that's an area that would need to
be looked at um and also you know a site
could be viable because it's a very flat
Greenfield site but but have no sort of
sustainable link to a settlements so it
it is one of balance councelor hes and I
think as we move forward with a new
local plan and Define the scope of the
Strategic viability appraisal um brief
for the local plan which we will engage
with jppc on then I think that's
something we absolutely need to look at
and make sure we we are giving it the
due consideration but at that
appropriate level can I just quickly ask
have you ever actually apply the overage
course yes so we are routinely doing
that now um
so the the SPD came in in July of of
22 and so on sites that that meet that
criteria of being over 100 units um so
on both the great toon creary and the
great toon meat factory we've introduced
review
mechanisms um and any whether it's
Brownfield or Greenfield where they
aren't meeting that affordable housing
level we we can and do apply that
overage overage Clause it's important to
do that particularly on larger sites
which may be built out over a
considerable period
so councelor Craig yeah thank you um
got the first is just the clarify that
my
understanding
if of
them the
war
um your experience how
counil can try
and speed at which they
are thanks thank
you first
first
so scheme is
to look at what
the
now
the proposal would be
unacceptable you know that that
recently with
rights given to affordable housing
certainly in our more rural areas our
local centers and Villages Ward members
have been very clear that actually
what's needed is affordable housing at
the at the expense of say an education
contribution the other obvious
contribution is public open space so um
th those those discussions are really
important and it's important to have it
on a site by site basis because the
needs of one community may may be
different so um whilst historically it
it has particular on larger sites it has
tended to be the affordable housing
that's squeezed we we are seeing a
slight shift in that and again that's
something that can be looked at moving
forward with a new local plan um in
terms of on-site delivery I think the
what what we can do as an authority is
is is firstly just make sure that we're
we're determining the applications in a
timely manner and securing as much of
fulling as we can of the right tenures
asking the questions particularly on
more rural side sites that um you know
is there a registered provider that
wants to come and bring these sites
forward because what we are increasingly
seeing is policy compliance scheme has
been secured in a village or a local
Center and actually they're built and
then the developer comes to us saying
well no registered provider wants to
take these so what we need to be doing
is at that application stage really look
at whether what we're securing is what's
needed for the community and whilst we
have that Target of 75 25% split just
being a little bit more sort of thorough
on that um also making sure that we are
determining housing applications well
all applications but appliations with
affordable um ensuring that they can get
on the site as quickly as possible the
SPD requires us to phase
alongside housing
so we
can't
where
to
Market
mechanisms responding to homes England
sort of consultations on those so all of
those things we can do um as with the
issues around 5y land Supply we can't
force people to get on site and build
but what we can do is ensure that we're
making it
as on site so um and if
there
application if an
RP
stage need to
be there's
no
forward
that will be somebody that will have a
lot of the ca do a lot of leas and work
that Helen talks about it also be
somebody that'll be discussing uh
development blockages with uh developers
and trying to you know free the wheels
if you like of development so that we
get Swift Delivery because as you can
see quite a lot of our affordable social
and other types of of housing are
delivered through the planning system um
that doesn't mean that's not going on at
the moment Helen's team do an awful lot
of that and you know touches on a point
that you made last night's full council
meeting about working with homes England
that's something that we routinely do
now um we make application to things
like the Brownfield land uh release fund
we talked to one public estate about how
do we try and free up some of these
sites and make it happen so that is
happening now but I do think that this
is a really important post that's coming
to to Helen team that will help that and
work with uh Council Hudson as the leag
member for housing on the housing
strategy work with Stacy housing team
and also make those links to planning
thanks yeah and sort of picking up that
point on the registered providers then I
presume that we have quite a good
relationship with a number of registered
providers and how do we go about
supporting them in both their own
developments and taking on uh these
properties from the
developers yeah I I I would say we do
have a good relationship with them um
Westwood housing has been the biggest
operator and they have taken a sort of
temporary step back from New Stock so
what that has enabled is other re other
RPS to come forward so um there's a
couple sites where we're seeing s North
de homes coming forward for example so
that that is beneficial in itself but in
in terms of keeping that good
relationship um sort of as I referred to
earlier we we do seek to have regular
contact regular meetings make ourselves
very available for those discussions and
and the new housing delivery lead that
will be there you know they will be
there to very proactively be contacting
the regional the register providers
looking at what's coming through the
system and when so we can then let our
housing we got that
real to
everything
it's
speed
it from
metal
just
AC we're currently sort of finalizing a
that will go
toward will provide some
input rather than necessarily
present
Council our
Dem
May so there
Mays for for that presentation probably
virtually but depends on how that's held
so the letter will sort of set out the
the dates and the options around that um
and then
experience he has said you know out of
that and this would be across you know
targeted to all parishes in the whole
District out of that there may be nine
or 10 parishes where there is
potentially a landowner and there is a
bit of momentum to bring something
forward so at that point then be a more
focused meeting with that specific
parish and land owners really to see the
mechanisms of how that could move
forward um there are sort of funding
issues at the moment around that support
for
clts um I think Devon communities
together there's potential funding there
to look at things like housing needs
surveys Parish needs surveys which would
need to be a starting point um but
certainly Middle March have committed to
working with us and and our new housing
delivery lead will be a key person
through the course of next year and
really
facilitate great wouldn't it to get some
really good schemes coming forward that
you know that we can sort of showcase so
thank
you um
years
ago
money and how that would
work I think it
was
between
that was intended to assist clts to uh
bring forward development so there is
that sitting in on our books as we
currently um that was I think 2019 and
we've never had an application to
it they presumably that could be used
through Parish
councils that is there
that
bring
hous in Middle
Tor something that members resolved at
that time
facilitate and
uh
Reserve
fun Mr T just to say it came through
this committee and was
agreed
2019 put
forward so it was very much supported
and it's in the system so yes I
think Council Craig yeah I just wanted
to ask as it a Loan Fund is there an
interest rate that's sort of attached or
is that negotiated with the with each
project comes
forward um I've got one comment I think
we're done got one
comment look at
page the the statistics that are
produced
there if um
hypothetically if developers were not
required
to
and
building 65
houses for social
rent
two me
we how well we're
doing so just cautious of how one
interprets things there's a lot
of there's a lot of people who
are to
make
new if we
would of
Social
and
the system that we have is
delivering we need to Aspire to get as
far to the 30% as possible but
um all all is not gloom and doom we
there there is you know there is
progress there there are there are
houses coming onto the market
um and um so you know you might shake
your head councel hes but actually this
the these are facts of units which are
being provided
um social rent ones they are yeah yeah
well I'm I'm using only the social rent
figures okay only the social rent
figures and uh very interestingly um
former Counselor Clark um in the last
Administration who was of course lead
lead member for housing at the time and
chatting uh with her and um she said
that when she first got
married um and lived in London and
turned up and as a couple they applied
for for Council
housing they didn't have nearly enough
points and they were told to get lost
and get on the list um that was 50 years
ago um and so you
just bear in mind that that there have
been um systems here which you know s
it's not all new or it's not all that
different um but I just look at those
figures and say fine okay I'm not saying
that we haven't got a problem but um we
mustn't be blind to actually what is
being produced um so we we are
frustrated that we're not closer to the
30%
um is the affordable housing need of
300 perom I think irrespective of
we or not I'd be
happy clearly
the
number
even problems
for
if Stacy could update us on how many
families are
in down
slightly 70s but we're now
approximately Helen saying
about and
we and I think
that
um
so my only concern and I may be you know
I don't I usually talk from a base I
don't know what I'm talking about which
just I'm doing again but those numbers
the thing that concerns me is that in
the current economic
climate seem to be or and it may
true with you
know to do
this down to
it we can't
actually
only
people
it's mixed in it's integrated
fully one would want to see for for
social I I
think
planning the
Supple
so
along 10 year
blind
um thank you very much in
indeed
is
next year right
um that's not a that's not a plan that's
been 100% resolved um I guess you know
what I'm saying now they might even be
watching but so so I have to stick to q1
you know that has to be the Target
because that that's when the other
elements can feed into it and it's
important that the findings from the
other activities feed into that so you
know there might be a logic in reporting
back on on that progress um so if we
were
talking 12 months
time to have an update as to how you're
getting on would that you you'd feel
that you should have um managed to get
some progress by then I would certainly
hope safe I mean you you mentioned q1
2024 there so you know I've gone to
q324 um um is that
well I think by q324 we'll have you know
we'll have
taken Pro it into a system and will have
gone through that that base level
strategic Asset Management thinking John
thank you very much indeed and the
councelor hes have been he's been waving
his one question please councelor one
one question one question one question I
feel quite vulnerable
sitting he was a he was a sleep earlier
but he's woking up
again welcome John emphasis on proactive
planning um ahead rather than reactive I
welcome the fact he's prioritizing
certain buildings for carbon
reduction oh thanks um my only yeah on
the sort of very base level everyday
level I'm concerned about the image of
this Council in terms of lot of its
properties for instance just in Northern
we've got the community center um in
northerm with its door patched up its
paint peeling its Windows falling to
bits when I was on a committee looking
after it we got grants and got it
looking really nice and now it looks
like a wreck it's a swimming pool in
torage that's got mold all over the
walls there's garage doors at wiill Lane
which look like they've not been painted
since the
1950s I Rely think you know we need to
look at our properties and do a bit of
sprucing up it's it's not just a matter
of cost it's you know that we're seen as
a council to be looking after our
properties really and in terms of listed
buildings I don't know whether that's
John's area or not but like in bridgland
Street those marvelous 17th century
buildings are falling to bits they're
listed there's one in Northern Square
the old school which has got plants
growing out of it and windows peeling so
you know generally I think we got poor
image at torage for property
maintenance
okay piece of context um and I think
it's extremely relevant in the public
sector and the private sector um there's
probably been quite a few events over
the past 15
years uh
around um financial crash
austerity
um more recently cost of living uh
inflation and uh as a general sort of
backdrop
um quite a lot of activities have been
cut you know Co covid was a more recent
one of
those I guess what what we've outlined
is is look um we're trying to get to a
point
where all of those points can be planned
on an annual basis I think you know
there there's a lot of catch up and
torage isn't unique in that
regard and I guess from my point of view
the priorities are always going to be
okay immediate health and safety and
compliance activities and that's what
the team's been focused
on and you know the point of the survey
the conditions surveys you know is that
we and both done internally and
externally is that we end up with a
program of activities that can influence
you know repairs decoration but also
where we can make some of those
interventions for savings as well so I
hope that gives the member comfort that
we're going along the right
track well if there's specific items
that need to be picked up out outside of
the room then happy to do that um listed
buildings only responsible from a from a
TDC assets point of
view um John thank you very much indeed
I would imagine we will look
to putting in uh an opportunity for you
to update Us in the sort of 12 to 18
months bracket somewhere around that no
point asking you to come and speak to
her until you've actually really had the
opportunity to implement the the the the
the very positive sounding um changes
that you've outlined today um and
certainly sounds like you'll end up with
a a model which will give you a much
better realistic picture of where you
are at any given state in time um rather
than just for a very small part of the
estate John thank you very much indeed
thank
you uh ladies and gentlemen right moving
to some in-house business now um and
that is the social value
policy uh and so turning to our own task
and finish group um to and you should
all have seen the draft that um uh we
have
on um page 25 on 20 page 25 onwards
who's talking us through this I can do a
brief inter
introduction
chair hopefully who's talking to this
one off you go John okay thank you um so
just as a reminder to the committee um
on the 12th of September uh this
committee agreed the terms of reference
for the social value task and finish
group and those terms of reference were
to draft a social value policy that is
linked to the council strategic
priorities is measurable manageable and
aligns to the National public sector
procurement bill so that was our
background to setting up the uh task and
finish group we've had a um a couple of
meetings one remotely and one um in
person uh We've drafted um a policy
that's in front of you today this policy
is uh based on the lga's district
council social value toolkit and it is
nearly 100% their template policy so
we've used that as a starting point uh
the committee um or the task and finish
group have met um debated in quite
detail we had a a good presentation from
the lead officer from ex who helps us
with the procurement side of things um
and that's what how how we've got to
where we are today chair um and I think
if I pass over to um uh the counselor
who was leading the uh the task and
finish group yes I apologize after you
started councelor craigy was was was the
lead on the task and finish group um so
I just asked you startop see see if you
were paying
attention mainly John
anyway um but yes we obviously we've um
gone through through the process of
looking at the um
of the national guidelines from the from
the LGA and are are thinking very much
for because this is something quite new
to us as a council that we stick as
closely as possible to
the how their sort of suggestions go
we've obviously discussed it in in
detail about how it might impact on the
small and local uh businesses here so we
very much emphasized the the recording
of the social value to reflect what
local businesses will already be doing
very well and it's about helping them
sort of demonstrate the social value
that they're already providing so that
it can be compared against those larger
companies that may be coming in from
elsewhere um and we've obviously got the
the four large themes that we would hope
will sort of um form part of the OB
reporting on the um social value um and
we've got I think it's 31 sort of
options
um within that obviously it's important
that any social value doesn't have to
provide on all of them um in theory it
only has to provide on one of them to
demonstrate the social value um but it
gives companies the ability to have a
wide ranging Choice um about what it is
that they're they're demonstrating um
and hopefully it fits in what they're
already doing in many cases most of the
local businesses will already be in that
field where they it's just a case of
recording it um obviously we also
thought it was important that we asked
North de plus um to provide some
assistance in understanding this when it
becomes uh goes out and that uh the
local
businesses will need a little bit of of
guidance so that um we're hoping to have
a few worked examples of guidance of how
how it's filled in so that the the
companies can basically record what
they're already likely to be doing um so
that we can demonstrate it and compare
across um the different offerings that
uh biders might make when they're
putting in for for contracts it's sort
of a
10% um social value uh on over
50,000 pound so it's it's not going to
sort of um impact the very small things
um that we procure but it will have a a
major KnockOn effect uh particularly if
we think think about the large sort of
things that are involved in with you
know the leveling up um Apple door
that's a significant um you know
contribution on on such a category and
if we make sure that a lot of it can
easily be from firms that are already
based and employing people in the area
they're already essentially meeting most
of it but if they're using um supplies
or employ employing people outside of
the area these are some of the things
that we we would see as beneficial to
the area and hopfully steers them in
that
direction and basically Havey have to
answer any questions or if we want to go
sort of specifically through the the
items I don't think we need to go
through it line by line
um in the tables at the back of it um
and
where proxy values are attached to each
um specific functional area where did
those where did where did those values
come from uh I think those values were
the one from the original Tate um that
that that that that they're they're
National values um but they are uh
adapted nationally for each local
Authority okay yeah I think um when we
have experience of this it may be
something that vary but when reach for
for for something that's I've got no
problem with with with with using a
national template at this stage and and
for goodness sake don't reinvent a wheel
um so um uh and anyway we probably don't
have any better information uh or data
with which to inform ourselves at this
moment so a number of the the items we
sort of uh left in um to review um if
there's nobody's put anything in um over
the 12 months um on certain it items to
to review whether we actually include
them as a a category at all because lack
of activity is always a sign as probably
not needed yeah but I think it gives a
broad enough range that there is
something that any you know contractor
can offer but a narrow enough range that
it's navigable by by the smaller
operators we had a chance to look at the
detail of this it's very
pretty
um Co Council
Hudson thank you chair um yes I took
part in the the working group for this
uh project and I think one of our joint
concerns was that we actually made sure
we could demystify it for small
businesses um who would like to Tender
for work but who go oh my goodness look
at the paperwork um large companies have
teams set aside to do all their uh form
filling and tick boox things so I think
the commitment from the working group
was to say this has got to be clear it's
got to be transparent there's got to be
uh the support available to small
businesses to say Don't Panic we don't
expect you to tick every box just look
at the ones you're doing and if you
actually focus in you're probably doing
it anyway so um I commend this as a
starting point for us to have something
that we can actually look at councelor
Craig has pointed out that if we're not
using some of the elements on this we
can think about removing them and make
it a bit more straightforward and maybe
add different ones in the future so
thank
you
Peter wants this obligatory
question
Sor call it your
record record yeah this is something
that uh on the climate working group
it's uh two three years ago I suggested
a procurement policy and we've been told
consistently since then we have to wait
for government proposals but it seems
from what this says that we could have
we had the power to actually produce our
own procurement
policy um all the way along um I hope
that this is going to go back to the
climate working group so that we can
input
into um a procurement policy for this
Council which which tries to get um
carbon reductions Energy Efficiency um
in the suppliers that we um engage um
this is something I welcome that that we
we've got to this stage but um we need
to do more work particularly on the
climate front thank
you with regard to its application to
social value and the CL this is social
value only so yeah so you know that goes
wider than necessarily just this so um I
wouldn't want this to be entirely
hijacked by something that was wider
than specifically focused social value
but yeah get absolutely get you on
it just just on that it is important to
note obviously that that we have valued
the reduction of uh carbon emissions
within a social value value context so
so obviously companies um say energy
providers that are have a lower carbon
intensity will be demonstrating social
value over and above those that don't so
I think
it's it does reflect environmental
things it's not not exclusively
environmental but uh I think the the
intention is that this would if this
committee agrees would go to CNR and
then full Council
for um not is there a need for further
consultation with outside groups before
in order to before we put it to CNR no
no CH as long as a committee happy it's
been through the task and finish group
it will if it's adopted it will need a
change to the contract procedur rules so
it will a separate report will go to um
audit and governance and then full
Council just to tweak the contract
procedur rules in line with the policy
but if the committee minded today then
they can recommend that recommend this
um policy to
CNR anybody have any further comment
nothing think sure
c c I know it was based on the national
template but it's just where it says in
there about well-being initiatives and
it says including physical activities
but I'm obviously thinking in our
strategic plan we've also mentioned
mental
well-being and cultural activities and
being lead member for culture I thought
I should can can we add anything in
there says initiatives taken or
supported to engage people in health
intervent it lists um stop smoking
obesity and well-being initiatives
including physical activities but
there's no explicit mention of mental
health which is obviously very important
in Tor we've been campaigning for it in
terms of the link center and I just sort
of um come back on there that obviously
uh in health intervention it doesn't
specifically mean physical it obviously
includes both um physical activities um
obviously are a therapeutic act rather
than it's relation to the physical
health obviously the the physical
activities may be impactful on Mental
Health um but we can probably um make it
clearer cultural activities as the sorry
that the these are actual National um
measures so it is just a guide from them
so it's not uh yeah not really ours to
OT it's uh it's it's we we've just
copied directly from the national um
themes outcomes and measures what what I
would say is in when in issuing the
guidance and understanding around it we
can
clarify what is meant by that so that
people are fully understand that it you
know it is both physical and mental
wellbeing that we're talking about um
because there's a number of them OB
obviously that like the ones that the um
redu measures in reducing crime which
are going to need a little bit of yeah
you know explanation before people
fully grasp grasp it just from that sort
of text explanation on there so I think
that's just about the guidance that we
issue around it as much as anything and
it and we do refer to um kind of mental
health in our po polic and legislative
context bit of the policy where we've
extracted from our strategic plan so it
does actually refer to that there as
well thank you I just wanted to raise it
that well that that's fair enough I I
there's actually quite a um there's a
lot of common sense in using and
sticking with at the moment a provided
um uh framework that's that that's been
handed
speak the time to to fine tune that more
to um local
circumstances
is at whatever point we say we want to
review it 12 months time after it's been
in in use um that's the opportunity at
which you can then get that experience
see what as you said see see which
measures are being
are active which aren't are the things
that aren't in here uh otherwise you
know one can get very carried away
trying to personalize the whole thing at
this stage when we don't actually um
have the knowledge as to how well it's
going to work um I think I think we did
we very much took the view that we
didn't want the perfect to be the enemy
of the good if we can get something
going then we can refine it on on that
practical experience and see how
actually steering the behavior of of
those that are um bidding for contracts
I deliberately delayed on this because
we were waiting for more direction from
the center now that we've got more
direction from the center it's sensible
that we use it
um
k sorry I don't want to be I rather
agree with
counselor
po that yeah the idea of a template is
that they lay out ideas for you which
you modify to circumstances it's not a
set in stone thing that you can't change
a word of and I think I agree
that you that you add in the mental
health thing because we know it's there
I mean we wait 12 months to know that
we've
got that issue or that cultural is
missing
I I don't understand
why I don't agree that a template you
have to use no you don't understand that
I'm not saying we can't change it we can
change it if we want to but actually
it's I would say it's quite good
practice just to take it as it is at the
moment I mean it's been put together
clearly with a certain amount of thought
and and and
um and you
know these are just B basic markers
running down it says involved people in
in health interventions well health
interventions covers the whole breadth
of Health um of which mental health is
only one everybody talks to me about
mental health at there's a whole range
of health issues which which affect
people and and so you know I just why
not just why not just keep it as a
headline um statement at the moment it's
just I think obviously from our
perspective it's about how it's
interpreted in the guidance to explain
it to uh uh organizations about you know
and well we we can change the the the
the wording at any one of these lines
actually how it's explained to those
people who are putting in bids is going
to have much more significance than the
final wording in any particular one case
there obviously going to be not got to
be yeah it's how you interpret it in
that that wider sense and as long as
it's clear to both off officers and
those that are you know putting in
procurement
tenders that it implies to all Health
criteria that's the important thing but
if it I mean I i' just say that you know
you've got Health interventions then and
then you've got an ex a list of examples
you have got specifics you have got
smoking a
you you've got a list so I think it's
not exp it expected to be an exclusive
list and know say suggestions but you
know we can we can tweak it if you'd
like well there is definitely a focus on
the physical health as all of the ones
listed are so it's not explicit so
Mark personally personally I'd take
these examples out yeah and I believe it
health inter interventions that I don't
need to be told what health
interventions are um you know and you
immediately set yourself up for a fall
by starting to put some because you
can't list them all why why give some
example take take them out yeah examples
in that was the template we were just
saying it's um happy to take those those
you know um because you could just have
initiatives taken or supported to engage
people in mental and physical health
interventions or well-being initiatives
in the community and that would be much
broader than happy with that change
because you take out the EG in Brackets
and you take out the including physical
activities CU that
need but it's obviously up to the
committee sorry chair just just to jump
in we can't change the terminology of it
because it is a national Tom so the
template was a document before that
these last the measures are that's how
they get the the the sum at the end the
actual um proxy value is worked out so
we we can check we could take out the I
EG for instance but we can't we got to
be careful not to change the meaning of
anything because it's that is based
nationally on the
toms H is suggesting actually changes
the meaning it just makes it it
clarifies the
meaning I'm cautious fine I'm not not
not D this but I that it shouldn't have
too much detail in a in a document like
this it should should talk talk in terms
of headl head headline um descriptions
um just before we go further um we are
about to come to the 3r Mark we we have
the to agree on this and then we have
the forward plan um and then we'll be
done so we won't go on much longer
however
um I need to move prove that we take
this meeting Beyond 3 hours um of which
um I will propose that yeah seconded by
uh councelor craigy can I have those
in supporting
that that's unanimous agreed to we am I
okay to continue yes good
always um okay okay
um I'm just thinking whe whether we
whether we want to take this as it is or
whether there's a need to refine it
further Mr Den chair if I can suggest
that where we've got to is a real move
forwards and I think learning through
experience from the measures that we've
got which are on the agree framework
which do have the national value
attached the difficulty with changing is
you've then got to quantify the value
which you can't do um so easily there is
a lot of work going on around the
well-being the health side that is um
developing through the social value engs
um so I expect we will see more measures
coming through I think we've got to
learn to walk with this policy and then
hopefully we'll be able to to run a bit
faster once it's up and
running
happy with that that makes sense to me
um from the chair I propose that we um
we accept this good piece of work from
task and finish group and we uh forward
it to C CNR next to CNR um can I have a
second for that please um councelor
Elliot those in favor please please sh
that's a unanimous uh thank you very
much task and finish
group
forward plan um which I've now wiped off
my machine back up again
no quick as a flash if we can bring it
up on it what was the answer to last
night's question if you can't use it go
and get trained wasn't that
answer anyway
right
so um we've
um heavy loading today we but important
that we actually crack through through
those and actually well done everybody
here
um cycle 6A which is the uh February
meeting is dedicated to the budget and
reviewing uh the draft budget and then
um uh in March um not only do we have
Cub R 3 but we also have the the review
of the QV process um by which stage we
will have had response from a
questionnaire that we'll be putting out
to all users so that'll be counselors to
um the omt and smt level of of of
officers um to uh try to solicit um
comment as to whether it can be improved
further um to make it more useful to to
to people
um
um the
um we've got social value policy in that
is that
expecting that was that was sorry sorry
CH no that was we put it in there so um
that it wasn't forgotten after the last
meeting and then you uh agreed that we
could put it into today's meeting right
okay so it can come
out so we're and it doesn't look like
the draft estry strategy is going to be
um anywhere around
there if if if I'm onest chair I I don't
think so no I mean there's there like I
said said there's that much work going
on the Porton har harbors and jety
studies coming through we've got a whole
piece of work going on around delivering
delivering the leveling up partnership
the same resource into that as we'll be
pulling together some of this so as it
stands I'm not certain that this is more
of a priority than those other pieces of
work and so I wouldn't uh say that that
will be there you did say I think though
for for April that you'd have Helen Back
yeah um it indeed uh in April
we we'll be looking at having an update
from the um planning manager
specifically on um the enforcement
capacity uh and how that's going
um can I just ask if we're not doing the
SG strategy then and bear in mind that
we put it as far back as we could to
allow for the maximum amount of time
when will we be getting confidence of
the reporting around it bear in mind
that the point of that report was
actually to look at the actions and
proposals being recommended two three
years ago that had been for the task and
finish
group and had gone forward with
recommendations that they went to the
business group to include we still have
no visibility of how any of those
actions have been delivered so to move
bit away because of future activities
doesn't give us an indication of where
we are
today
um I hear all of that um I my
understanding is that the the draft Esty
strategy H has been rather overtaken in
a way
by a a new Focus that is Fallen upon the
whole of the estri the harbor The
Maritime Center everything there in
terms of the the the the questioning of
the viability of continuing to have try
to be a commercial Port here and what
what really do we want to use that EST
that
Harbor assets for and and so I think
it's this is where I've been trying to
lead a discussion with counselor hex um
I haven't got very far yet but uh in the
and it it's it's a big but actually
it's I I'm thinking you know we've got
my my good friend here who will Who will
who will be bashing the bashing the
Heritage work and and and and all of
that
um are we actually using all of
that for the right thing at the right
time in this day and age and for the
next 50 years you know um it's an asset
and it needs to work in order to either
bring people with money in their pockets
into this area or to generate hard
income as a commercial business um but
we've got to stop wandering around with
rose tinted glasses on
and having Misty eyed views of History
um it's what is it now and in the future
and we're been told on the one hand ra
rather um um optimistic reports I think
we all thought from the Harbor Master
saying that there was going to be you
know um the the country's fourth largest
container Port com going to be built
down there fairly soon um or um the the
the the realism
that actually a shallow
water um tidal estery um in modern
shipping terms it it a lot of it is
wishful thinking but it's not going to
happen um and we need at some stage to
to really get some detail science and
and data behind all of this to to find
out actually really really what is what
is going to be happening so I see this
all wrapping into into one um uh and it
affects as much what happens on the
Harbor as it does in the wider confines
of the a I I was going to say if if the
pors harbors and Jetties plant element
is ready should we not just look at that
at that stage and and as a partial step
towards reviewing the whole S3 plan the
bit that's ready if you like have a look
at can I that is a possibility uh sorry
Sor I was just going to add a
supplementary to that yeah just explain
that it's going to Harbor board that
document will progress next to Harbor
board for debate so I guess then you
know de whatever harbard board resolved
to do I guess would be availab available
to
scrutiny
okay where I was going was bearing in
mind the recommendations from
2014 and the review that happened two
three years ago and the recommendation
from that can we even if nothing else
have a grid showing where they've gone
to and who's picking them up and where
they're going to form part of the new
strategy so that we know that everything
that or if they've just been deleted in
the sense that no longer valid let's at
least close it down to the point that we
have full visibility over all the
recommendations so that we can come back
in the future and it's not an open book
we can say that's now this that's now
this that's closed that's been replaced
by
this yeah happy happy for that to
produce that document for for April I
say my concern was around the production
of a new strategy and I don't think that
was feasible but a review of strategy
review of est3 strategy recommendations
and what what's likely to be carried
forward what's emerging as an
opportunity to be carried forward I
think we can summarize that in the table
for
you the work that's being done
e
on the harb and I know the end of the
day with with the economic strategy
everybody's very busy but where is that
sitting and when we like to see the
strategy because we're no longer working
on a strategy it's gone out to
date the economic strategy you're
talking about Mr yeah so we're looking
at a draft in the new year so should be
ready in January um so yeah that it's on
a quite a tight timeline because what
the northern never one yeah the northern
one yeah so we're on quite a tight
timeline for that now because we'd like
to have that in place before we enter
into the leveling up partnership
discussions it's an important evidence
document for the leveling that
partnership discussion so we need to
have that adopted by the end of March so
a draft in January would be
logical do we want to see that in
February I think that would beuse it I'm
just trying to think of it's It's rout
to a option and whether we would having
having having to come to a February
meeting would hold it back from being
adopted in time for the par discussion I
haven't got the committee schedules in
front it's on our watch list yeah
um go to CNR yeah it will go to CN
undoubtedly have to go to full Council
for
adoption so it Go CNR full Council yeah
and and and and then if you factor into
the ability for calling there's a a
complicated route to adoption
potentially oh I see okay
yeah opportunity for members to get
engage in it not necessarily in this
committee Forum um so it's not going to
just arrive at full Council um UNC
consulted on that there will it will go
to uh CNR beforehand and a
recommendation from CN AR for canc will
be made so if at any point then
obviously that's the scrutiny function
you can call it to this committee offers
will have the opportunity to everybody
will have the opportunity to to see it
as it goes to
CNR and we can then
um discuss that having listened to CNR
looking at it and if there's an issue
then we'll call it
in um off CNR before it goes to that
would then have to go back to yeah but
fine it complicates the route to
adoption but it's Constitution says
you've got the ability to do that yeah I
mean that's only if there was a we had
grounds for doing so I accept that okay
um right so um with in the April meeting
we're taking out the entry that says
social value policy because we've done
that but we've got ground maintenance
review uh in there and we are looking at
the review of all the various
recommendations which have been made
regarding the S3 strategy and a
discussion um with
um the economic development officer and
possibly Harbor Master would be useful
well yes har Master actually that's
probably quite a good idea he could then
come in we could then have a direct
conversation about um um right okay um
that's fine any else anybody wants to
mention on the for
plan good that
be